protesters just swarmed VI ramaswami
while he was on the campaign Trail and
VI in characteristic form answers all of
their questions before one of them
rammed into him with a car do you think
Ukraine should be free Ukraine should be
a Sovereign Nation absolutely the US how
is the US going to how is the US
negotiate negotiate a path to peace that
allows ukra come out with sovereignty
intact well what does that sovereignty
look like to you that NATO will not Adit
that sovereignty look like to you a hard
commitment that does that sovereignty
look like to you question whenever
you're tell me when you're done and then
I'll answer the question answer the
question NATO will not admit Ukraine to
Nato and should not admit Ukraine to
Nato because we made a commitment in
1990 and I believe in standing by our
commitments that NATO would not expand
one inch not one inch past East
Germany made a commitment that it would
not expand his
territory I'm going to do what I want to
say is I'm very glad that young people
are engaged and passionate about these
issues so the fact of the matter is I
believe it St our commitments but the
job of the US president to look after us
interests and have a reasonable path to
peace that Ginger Punk is getting my
blood boiling because VI is of any
presidential candidate in the race VI is
the most gracious about answering
people's questions debating openly and
he's trying to answer the question and
this kid won't stop speaking and is just
mouthing off to his better it's just so
outrageous that NYU Professor wants to
teach mating Dynamics we need to teach
respect we need to teach civility we
need to teach punks having some proper
attitude toward their betters and people
who are graciously answering questions
but anyway that's a that's a minor point
the vake graciously answers the
questions and then one of these punks
gets in his car flips off the vake and
Rams his car into VI's car and you can
tell it's a liberal car that that did
the ramming because they're all these
sorts of silly bumper stickers all over
it and and hits the back of AES car A's
fine
uh the person who did this needs to go
to prison for a long
time look it's great that maybe AES got
a little Whiplash or something I don't
even know if he was in the car at the
time but he's
okay this is political violence this
this is
along the spectrum of assassination okay
this this is establishing the principle
that if if you pose a question to a
presidential candidate and the
presidential candidate even answers you
and you don't like that answer that you
can commit violence against that person
the v's got two small kids what if those
two kids were in the
car a grown man can handle being hit in
the back of a car at a relatively low
speed what if it were a little kid what
if he weren't in a seat right what if
any of these things something could
could have gone really really wrong here
and according to the news reports this
morning the protesters got off the hook
oh they said it was an accident no big
deal that protester should rot in prison
for
years that is not not only an attempt at
committing violence against a
presidential candidate that is violence
that's serious violence and someone
could have gotten seriously hurt if not
killed but our liberal ruling class
doesn't care about that our liberal
ruling class encouraged protesters just
like those punks and even more violent
than those punks to burn the country
down for eight months and to loot and to
steal and to assault and to murder
people dozens of people were killed in
the BLM riots that were incouraged by
our liberal establishment where the
riers were bailed out of jail by the
Vice President of the United States the
current vice president kamla Harris by
staff members for the president of the
United States Joe Biden
this is not an example of wow look how
far things have gotten someone hit V's
car we got to pull back a little this is
a promise of things to come if the
conservatives continue to pull well in
this election it's going to get a lot
worse than this if the Liberals feel
that they're going to lose their grip on
power we got to talk about that when you
want to talk to your friends you got to
check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com NOS you know a company's
looking at for you when they actually
upgrade your service and don't charge
you for it this is great news for new
and current P talk customers P talk just
added data to every plan plus every plan
now includes a mobile hotspot with no
price increase whatsoever if you've
considered peer talk before but haven't
made the switch take a look again for
just 20 bucks a month you will get
unlimited talk text and now 50% 5% more
5G data plus their new mobile hotspot
this is why I love Pure Talk they're
veteran-owned and only hire the best
customer service team located right here
in the good old U of A P talk families
are saving almost $1,000 a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that do not
support you when you go to peer talk.com
cwle you will save an additional 550%
off your first month because they value
you go to Pur
talk.com palk Wireless for Americans by
Americans speaking of public office and
death uh John Kirby who is the spokesman
for the
NSC uh he previously was a spokesman at
the Pentagon now he's just in another
sort of version of that role at National
Security Council uh John Kirby was asked
about Senator Tommy tuberville's hold on
top brass military
confirmations uh because the military is
now insisting on paying service members
to travel out of state to kill their
children and senator tuberville says
this is completely insane this is not
what the American people want this is
contrary to our values and so we're
going to hold up the confirmations of
the very tippy top brass at the Pentagon
until you guys get rid of this new and
completely insane policy so the the
Pentagon is at a standstill in terms of
its promotions reporter asks John Kirby
hey is the Pentagon going to Cave to the
senator and the desires of the people
and the civilian political order here's
John Kirby's response isn't keeping that
abortion policy in place in effect
superseding national uh security how I'm
not sure I understand you want to get
the nominations through right you take
back the polic oh so you so the
suggestion is that we should just turn
our backs no I get it I didn't say it
was yours but the suggestion is we
should just turn our backs on one in
five of every every person in the United
States military to let alone their
family members just so we can get these
these officers confirm that's the
suggestion that I think you're put a
pause here
please one in five members of the US
military is regularly killing her
children one in I don't believe that
statistic I don't think one in five
members of the US military at any given
time is
murdering her
children I does Kirby mean that one in
five members of the military is a woman
and that a woman essentially needs the
right quote unquote to kill her children
what the hell is he talking about and
that just would be an egregious
violation of the Covenant
that we make the the military makes the
people that sign up and volte Mur
children remember this they're
volunteers there's not conscription
there's no draft people volunteer for
this and when they volunteer for that
Duty they have every right to expect
that they're going to get the health
care they need and let me tell you
something else a healthy force is a
ready Force so don't talk to me about
National Security being impaired um uh
the one impairing National Security is
Senator
chville okay senator chville who doesn't
understand that if our military
servicemen and women cannot Slaughter
American children willy-nilly whenever
they want regardless of state laws then
we're not going to be ready to go fight
proxy wars for
Ukraine or whatever we're doing now
that's that's crazy that's crazy that is
crazy the purpose of the United States
military is to kill our
enemies the purpose of the United States
military is not to kill our own children
if top brass at the
Pentagon is confused on this matter then
the top brass at the Pentagon needs to
go and at the very least they're not
going to get their promotions and
they're not going to get their
confirmations I generally like John
Kirby he's fine I he's got an impossible
job flacking for this awful
Administration that has very evil
priorities at the top of their list so I
I have a bit of pity for him but this
answer was egregious absolutely
egregious he he talks about the the
sacred Covenant that we've made with our
service members get those words out of
your mouth get those words out of your
Blasphemous sacriligious
mouth sacred Covenant to murder children
that's a sacred Covenant with molok
that's a sacred Covenant with the bals
it's a sacred Covenant with baffet the
Devil Himself it's not a sacred Covenant
with God there's nothing sacred about
it
Senator chville is a hero I am so so
pleased that that man is standing up for
what is right what is most basically
right which is
that our our government should not be
our our US military should not be going
out of its way to undermine the laws
passed by the duly elected
representatives of the people of the
many of these states to protect children
from being slaughtered by psychos are we
the baddies when did we become the
baddies I don't want to be the baddies
and in as much as top military brass are
the baddies they got to go I I'm now
beginning to think not only should we
hold up their
promotions we should just fire them
anyone anyone who in any way is
associated with this egregious policy
should be fired should just be released
from the military get them out of there
I don't want them anywhere near our
military they're very confused about the
purpose of the military which is to kill
the enemy not to kill the little
innocent babies here in America quite
the opposite and Kirby's got to go too
Kirby's got to go to what a disgusting
display from him boy what a great clip
that was now stop hold on stop stop stop
stop stop ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael nlls YouTube channel and
we'll see you next time